[Music]
[Music]
please welcome television academy
chairman and ceo frank shirma
good morning thank you for joining us
for the 2022 emmy awards nominations
announcement i'm always thrilled to be
up nice and early for this announcement
because as the kickoff to the
entertainment industry's absolute
biggest night
over the last few years i've watched as
television has kept the world
entertained informed and connected and
now i'm excited to see where we go from
here
we are breaking records with the number
of submissions received by the
television academy this year which tells
me two things one production is at an
historic high and two the quality of the
shows we are all watching is also at an
all-time high
when we make our announcements in a few
short minutes it will reflect only a
fraction of the incredible television
being made right now
i couldn't be prouder of all the work
being done in our industry no matter
where it is distributed you are the
innovators creators and storytellers
that are pushing this platinum age of
television literally out of the box
we are watching the television audience
being entertained by the multitude of
choices being put in front of them
this morning we are thrilled to have
with us two of television's most
talented stars to announce the 2022 emmy
nominations starring together in the
upcoming series blockbuster on netflix
please welcome from hbo's curb your
enthusiasm emmy award-winning actor jb
smoove and from nbc's brooklyn nine-nine
currently streaming on peacock actress
and director melissa's melissa fumero
thank you frank what a thrill it is to
be here this morning with you all you
are absolutely right especially for me
how often do i get the honor of
announcing the 2022 emmy nominees with
two of my favorite people in hollywood
it's just the two of us jp i hate to
correct you while we're rolling melissa
but it's three's company today you me
and my little emmy right here oh my god
she's beautiful i know i know i know
isn't she the best almost a year old now
um
can i hold her
okay yeah yeah of course you can
support the head
that's it that's it you got it
hi emmy i'm your
a little shy okay no i i get it i get it
i'm not into it take it personally
oh and she's about to get some siblings
because we're about to announce a whole
round of nominations so many new emmys
coming your way in just a few short
months well let's get to it
let me
oh my god
our first category is for outstanding
variety talk series and here are the
nominees
i know i know the daily show with trevor
noah if you go without electricity for a
weekend you're camping if you go without
it for 50 years you're amish
[ __ ] that's just who you are
jimmy kimmel lies on me believe it or
not this has never happened to me in my
life
i tweeted back i wrote officer i'd like
to report a joke
last week tonight with john oliver space
and they just thought it would be
better suited for a comedy show and and
not with what you were doing yeah i get
it you're being mean to me late night
was seth myers
[Applause]
the late show with stephen colbert
europe since world war ii and the whole
world is in shock
that's why today's wordle was
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding variety talk series
our next category is for outstanding
competition program here are the
nominees
the amazing race good luck
travel safe
[Music]
go lizzo's watch out for the big girls
for me okay yes ma'am yes i'm ready
nailed it
you in danger girl all right since today
is all about jacques i keep telling
myself okay i have to impress jacques
rupaul's drag race
welcome to the main stage of rupaul's
drag race top chef here i am super
worried about time
are you going to be okay yeah i burned
the whole case
the voice speechless you really did i
hope you can leave kelly's speechless
you know what i'm a talker myself girl
thank you look we have so much in common
already not as much as you and i have in
common
congratulations to the outstanding
competition program nominees who do we
have next
[Laughter]
next we have the nominees for
outstanding league actress in a comedy
series and here they are
rachel bronson
the marvelous mrs maisel
quinta brunson abbott elementary
kelly coco
the flight attendant
l fanning the great
issa rae insecure
jane smart hacks
these are the nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a comedy series
congratulations
and now here are the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series
donald glover atlanta
bill hader barry
nicholas holt the great
steve martin only murders in the
building
martin short only murders in the
building
sudeikis ted lasso
these are the nominees for outstanding
lead actor in a comedy series
the next category is outstanding comedy
series let's check them out
abbott elementary we are admin we are
social workers we are therapists we are
second parents very purpose hank body
forgiveness is something that has to be
earned
curb your enthusiasm caftan kind of a
sir captain-ish yeah there's a hood
is it for a man or a woman no it's for a
man well what kind of a man a clansman
hacks
because you're advanced now
[Music]
so go kill him
okay
okay okay
the marvelous mrs maisel that's not how
the business works
then let's change the business
only murders in the building we gotta
break the door down excuse me we weigh
125 combined oh thank you it's the dips
ted lasso
okay just huffing and puffing around the
pitch uh-uh no thank you the only face i
want to see from y'all is what coach can
facebook
what we do in the shadows
[Music]
congratulations to all the nominated
outstanding comedy series
let's see who the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a limited or
anthology series or a movie
colin firth the staircase
andrew garfield under the banner of
heaven
oscar isaac scenes from a marriage
michael keaton dopesick
kimesh patel station
11. sebastian stan pam and tommy
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a limited or
anthology series or movie
and now i have the nominees for
outstanding league actress in a limited
or anthology series or a movie
tony colette the staircase
julia garner and vinnie anna
lily james bam and tommy
sarah paulson impeachment american crime
story
margaret quali maid
amanda seifried the dropout
these are the nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a limited or anthology
series or movie congratulations everyone
next up we have the nominees for
outstanding limited or anthology series
here they are
dope
[Music]
i can't believe how many of them are
good now
the dropout new technology new
technology this is
an inspiring step
forward
every day men do far worse things than
anything i've allegedly done and what
happens to them nothing no consequences
no fallout and definitely no jail time
pam and tommy yeah dude all the time
ever since i started you know it's just
been like way more chilling
hey
hey
get the [ __ ] out of here the white
lotus i just want to skip all the layers
and just go straight to the crazy and
just like you know let the chips fall
where they may and you know just show
them just
show them the core of the onion
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding limited or anthology series
next up are the nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a drama series
and here they are
jody comer killing eve
laura lenny ozark
melanie linsky yellow jackets
sandra oh killing eve
rhys witherspoon the morning show
zendaya euphoria
these are your nominees for outstanding
lead actress in a drama series
and now here are the nominees for
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
jason bateman
ozark
brian cox succession
lee zhang jay squid game
bob odenkirk better call saul
adam scott severance
jeremy strong succession
these are the nominees for outstanding
lead actor in a drama series
congratulations everyone
congratulations
okay here's our final category for the
morning outstanding drama series and
here are the nominees
better call song
[Music]
euphoria
ozark
you're excited about this
you were a good salesman
severance
[Music]
squid game
[Music]
stranger things
succession
love
you should have trusted me
yellow jackets
[Music]
congratulations to the nominees for
outstanding drama series
and of course congratulations to all the
nominees for this year's emmy awards you
can find the full list of nominees
online at
tune in for the 2022 creative arts emmy
awards airing saturday september 10th at
8pm on
fxx and join us for the 2022 emmy awards
monday september 12th at 8pm eastern 5
p.m pacific on nbc thanks to everyone
who joined us this morning and thank you
jb for doing this with me
i'll announce anything with you girl and
you know that we are we come on we're
co-stars now same same
have a great day everyone
i got a baby to go burp come on
[Music]
[Music]
you